المترجم: Mennatullah Mustafa
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
يعطيكم العافية،
سوف نرجع إلى هذه.
الصورة النمطية والمعروفة عنّي والمشهور بها
ليست بالزي الرسمي،
وإنما بزي الحرب.
مثل تلك الصورة بواسطة رسام
كاريكتير أُعجب بمسيرتي الإعلامية،
فقام برسمي.
الصورة دائمًا مربوطة بالخوذة، بالدرع،
بالصحافة، بالحروب والتغطيات الصعبة،
بالقصف والدمار والمعاناة والحصار.
الكثير من الصور العنيفة والمؤلمة،
هذا هو حال الواقع في غزة.
لكن يمكن لتلك الصور أن تؤثر على كثير
من المتابعين والمشاهدين،
لأني قبل كوني صحفيًا، أنا إنسانٌ عاديّ.
أترغبون في رؤيتي طفلًا كيف كنت؟
هذه صورتي وأنا صغير،
يشبهني قليلًا، ربما كنت أجمل بطفولتي.
في صغري، كان لديّ طموحٌ مختلف،
كان لي اتجاه آخر بحياتي،
كنت محبًا جدًا لكرة القدم،
وكنت أقضي الكثير من الوقت
في ساحتي الشعبية بحيّ الشيخ رضوان
في غزة، ألعب كرة القدم.
حتي بأوقات دراستي، كان طموحي أن أصبح
لاعب كرة،
أرتدي قميص رقم 10،
وهذا رقم شائع لمحبي كرة القدم.
في عام 1994، تحقق جزء من حلمي،
حيث تم اختياري كلاعب في منتخب
فلسطين لكرة القدم للأشبال.
(تصفيق)
هذه صورتي مع منتخب فلسطين الذي شارك
في بطولة النرويج الدولية لكرة القدم.
ولتوفير الوقت عليكم، سأخبركم موضعي من
الصورة،
هو أنا على جهة اليمين في الجلوس.
على أقصى اليمين.
كنت قائد الفريق،
وعلى الرغم من أن التحدي كان كبيرًا،
إلا أن فرحتي كانت أكبر، لأنني حققت طموحي،
حققت أول خطوة بحلم لاعب الكرة.
وفرحة أخرى، لأنها كانت صفحة جديدة
من حياتي،
فهي المرة الأولى التي سأغادر فيها قطاع
غزة، المرة الأولى التي أركب فيها
طائرة، المرة الأولى التي أري فيها مطار،
المرة الأولى التي أرى فيها أشخاصًا جدد
لم أتعرف بهم قبلًا.
بقدر ما كانت الفرحة بهذه الصفحة الجديدة،
بقدر ضخامة الصدمة التالية،
إذا أردت أن تسافر خارج بلدك فإلامَ تحتاج؟
جواز سفر.
أنا لست عجوزًا أو كبيرًا في العمر،
أنا عندي 32 سنة،
لكن بعام 1994، في حالة احتياجك للسفر،
فسوف تحتاج إلى وثيقة سفر تصدرها
سلطات الاحتلال الإسرائيلي،
يسمونها وثيقة سفر،
لم يكن هناك ذلك الجواز الجديد
الذي تصدره السلطات الفلسطينية هذه الأيام.
تمكنت أنا وبقية أعضاء الفريق من الحصول
عليه.
كانت بياناتي كلها صحيحة،
اسمي وعمري ومكان ميلادي
وأيضًا صورتي،
الصورة التي رأيتموها منذ قليل.
الصدمة كانت في أن جنسيتي
كانت غير محددة.
غير معرفة، غير معترف بها،
أمثل منتخب فلسطين،
وألعب لصالح فلسطين.
لكن أمام الورق والعالم،
صاحب جنسية غير محددة،
غير معروفة، وغير معترفٍ بها.
كانت تلك الصدمة الأولى بالنسبة لي،
والصدمة الثانية حدثت لحظة وصولي
للنرويج.
كنت -مثلما حدثتكم- قائد الفريق والمتحدث
باسمه.
وكنا متحمسين جدًا لبدء اللعب.
كان أصعب شيء مررت به، هو عندما بدأنا
الاحتكاك باللاعبين وأصحاب المنتخبات
الدولية هناك.
لازلت أذكر ذلك الموقف إلي الآن.
حيث سألني أحد لاعبي المنتخبات الدولية،
"ما اسمك؟"
اسمي تامر.
"من أين أنت؟"
من فلسطين.
"باكستان؟"
لا، فلسطين!
تركني ورحل غير مدرك لجنسيتي،
وظللت أنا واقفًا مكاني،
أحدث نفسي،
ألهذه الدرجة بلدي مجهول!
من هنا، اكتسبت أول دافع لي،
وحُزت أول رسالة بحياتي،
وأول اختبار حقيقي،
اختبارًا كان أكبر من عمري،
وأصبح التحدي ليس تسديد هدف
في المرمى،
ليس الفوز بالكأس،
ليس الفوز بالبطولة في المنتخب،
بل أصبح التحدي هو جنسيتي، قضيتي،
هويتي، وطنيتي أمام العالم.
(تصفيق)
ولأجل هذا، كانت
البداية والدافع لي لدخول عالم الإعلام.
لم يكن الإعلام بالنسبة لي وظيفة أو عمل
أو قسم بالجامعة،
بل لأنه رسالة وقضية ووطن.
من هنا بدأت رحلة تامر المسحال
الصحفي، الطفل الذي تربي من أصل
عائلة مهاجرة، من قرية الجورة قضاء عصقلان،
الذي ولد في معسكر الشاطئ للاجئين،
ليس بعيدًا عن هنا.
الذي قُدر له أن يعيش طفولته الأولى في
فترة الانتفاضة الأولي،
على وقع الغاز المسيل للدموع، ومنع التجوال،
والاقتحامات، وتكسير العظام.
وقُدر له أن يبدأ دراسته الإعلامية في
الجامعة الإسلامية بقسم الصحافة
والإعلام تزامنًا مع الانتفاضة الثانية
بعام 2000.
وشاءت الأقدار، أنه عند انضمامي للجزيرة،
كانت أول تغطية صحفية كبيرة لي
وقت حرب 2008.
تلك الحرب العنيفة الشنيعة،
في حرب 2008، كنت حديث الزواج،
من زوجتي التي ترافقني هنا،
وبدلًا من تقضية شهر زواجي،
قضيت شهر القصف،
في الوقت الذي يفترض بي أن أكون
قريبًا من عائلتي، ابتعدت عنهم.
ابتعدت عنهم، لتأدية رسالة الحقيقة.
ورسالة البحث عن المعلومة، ونقل الصورة.
في كل يوم كنت أتنقل فيه بين ظروف
الحرب المختلفة -كالمعلقين
بين السماء والأرض-
كنت أتسائل هل من الممكن في أي وقت
أن يظهر خبر عاجل على شاشة الجزيرة،
أو أي شاشة أخرى:
استشهاد الزميل الصحفي تامر المسحال!
لم أكن خائفًا من القدر، بقدر خوفي من عدم
قدرتي على الإجابة على كثير من الأسئلة
التي تسبب القلق لي.
كيف سيكون شعور أمي وقتها؟
أبي، زوجتي، عائلتي، زملائي،
أصدقائي،
لأني مررت بتجربة فقدان زملاء لي
في ميدان الإعلام والعمل.
قصتي وهمي الذي أحمله كان صغيرًا
مقارنةً بالعديد من القصص التي قمت بتغطيتها
لا يمكنني أن أنسى الطفل لؤي صبح،
ذلك الطفل الذي فقد بصره نتاج لقذيفة
دبابة قصفت منزله،
كنت الصحفي الأول الذي التقي به
بعد وصوله إلى مشفى الشفاء.
حيث أجريت لقاء مباشر معه.
ما أتذكره وعلق في ذهني وقتها،
أنه في نهاية اللقاء المباشر-
(تصفيق)
في نهاية اللقاء المباشر،
بين ألمه وفقدان بصره،
قال لي: "شكرًا يا عمو على اللقاء."
على الهواء مباشرة.
لا يمكنني أن أنسى جميلة الهباش،
تلك الفتاة الفلسطينية- اليوم هي فتاة،
لكن وقت اللقاء كانت طفلة وأصيبت
وبُترت قدماها-
كانت تلعب فوق سطح منزلها،
وبعد انتهاء اللقاء قالت لي:
"عمو، أتمني أن أكون صحفية."
والآن جميلة تدرس الصحافة وأصبحت
صحفية.
(تصفيق)
لا يمكنني أن أنسى فراس،
الذي أعاد لي كل ذكرياتي
من الجنسية والهوية وجواز السفر
والتنقل بحرية.
فراس كان الطفل الأول لأبيه وأمه وفرحتهم
الأولى،
قُدر له أن يولد بمرض في قلبه.
عائلته كانت ميسورة الحل وبمقدرتها
أن تعالجه بأي مكان،
لكن التحدي بالنسبة لهم هو خروجه
من غزة، لعدم وجود مشفى كفء
في غزة لعلاج حالته، تبعًا
لوضع غزة المحاصرة
الذي بات معروفًا للجميع.
حاولت عائلة فراس لسنتين الخروج من قطاع
غزة، لكن دون جدوى.
كانت كاميرتي حينها ليست إعلامية فقط،
بل إنسانية أيضًا.
شعرت أنه ربما تستطيع
الكاميرا أن تؤدي الدور
الذي عجز عنه جواز السفر،
جواز السفر غير المعترف به،
والذي لا سلطة له في التنقل.
(تصفيق)
الحمدلله، نجحت مع طاقمي في العمل
وكاميرا الجزيرة أن يتمكن فراس من السفر
لتتم معالجته، وأن ترافقه أمه في
رحلة العلاج.
وفي اليوم الذي كان من المفترض فيه
أن يسافر فراس للخارج،
وعند وصول سيارة الإسعاف لخارج بيته،
تلقينا اتصالًا غيّر مسار الأحداث.
أين هو؟ أين فراس؟
(بكاء)
أين فراس؟
حبيبي يا فراس.
يا روحي يا فراس.
يا روحي..
(تصفيق)
مات فراس، وحصل على جنسية شهيد.
ككثير من الأطفال في فلسطين.
اسم فراس كان فراس المظلوم،
ليست صفة،
بل كان من عائلة المظلوم، عاش في حي من
أحياء غزة.
فراس اسم على مسمى، ظُلم في أبسط حقوق
حياته.
لم تكن القصة إعلامية، كانت إنسانية،
لأني كنت أستعد لاستقبال طفلي الأول كريم.
قصة تتبع قصة، مأساة تعقبها مأساة،
حرب أولى وثانية وثالثة،
ولا نعلم إن كان ثمة حرب رابعة أم لا،
إن شاء الله نتمنى ألا يكون هناك حروب،
لكن الدرس الذي تعلمته في الصحافة، ولمدة
15 سنة عملًا بها،
بدأت بها كمتدرب بسيط حتى وصلت إلى
كوني إعلاميًا أتحدث إليكم،
هو أن الصحفي حقًا غير محدد الجنسية.
بلا جنسية.
(تصفيق)
الصحفي ليس بحاجة إلى جنسية لينقل
الحقيقة،
الصحفي لا يحتاج جنسية لتمكنه
من توصيل المعلومة،
الصحفي ليس بحاجة إلى جنسية
لنصرة المظلومين،
لذلك لم تقتصر تغطيتي على غزة فقط،
بل كان لي تجربة في سوريا،
وفي ليبيا وفي مصر،
في ربيع الثورات العربية.
اليوم أقول أن جنسيتي هي إنسانيتي،
جنسيتي هي قضيتي،
جنسيتي هي مهنيتي، التي عبرت بها كل
الحدود، ولم تقف تلك الحواجز عائقًا عن
توصيل صوتي وصوت شعبي،
وهي رسالتي إلي كل العالم.
وهويتي التي أفتخر بها،
التي حصلت عليها من أبناء شعبي،
(تصفيق)
حصلت على هويتي من أبناء شعبي بعد
51 يومًا من الحرب،
في اللحظات الأولى التي اتجهت فيها إلى
ميدان السرايا في وسط مدينة غزة
في اللحظات الأولى بعد انتهاء الحرب.
"تامر، تامر، تامر، تامر.."
أقول في إنهاء كلمتي أنهم رفعوني على
أكتافهم، والآن أعدهم وأعدكم وأعد
نفسي، أني سوف أحملهم بهمومهم
وآلامهم وأملهم دومًا على رأسي.
(تصفيق)